>>John: We very much know
that authentic assessment is having
a positive impact on the students
for the simple reason they know
where they are at any given time.
Whether it's a project-based
assessment,
a performance-based assessment,
these are very much more authentic
and kids find it much more
difficult because we're asking them
to not learn a procedure
and spit it back out again,
but to understand a concept
that procedure represents.
>>Andy: Exhibitions are an exit
requirement at School of the Future,
and the idea of the exhibitions is
to write eight to ten-page papers
that use the habits of mind
to make informed arguments
about a particular topic.
So for instance, a math student
might write a math exhibition looking
at the geometry of bridges.
A social studies student might
write an exhibition on analysis
of advertising towards children.
Whatever they do, it always has
to have these habits of mind,
point of view, evidence,
connections, significance,
alternative points of view.
What we're really trying to do in
each subject is to teach these habits
of mind through this authentic
process of writing a paper.
So for instance, Esther,
who's the ninth grade teacher,
has incredible exhibitions that
come regularly out of her class.
Things that you would be shocked.
These are ninth grade exhibitions
that are extremely well-written, 15,
20 pages exploring controversial,
thought-provoking stuff
in rigorous intellectual ways.
>>Esther: So if we're doing
exhibitions, first obviously we work
on essential question,
thesis, outline,
but then they write
the first argument
and then we revise the first
argument until it's ready to go.
Second argument, third argument,
and then at the end of the year,
you obviously have the whole paper.
And in the same way, if
we're doing graphic novels,
first they'll write a story, and
then they turn that into a script
so they have all the dialogue ready,
and then they do a storyboard,
and then they make the
actual graphic novel.
All those things in between will
grade the script that they write,
and will give a little
grade to the storyboard.
We'll see how they're
progressing in these skills,
but it's all towards
the same final piece.
>>David: There was a particular
unit that she did in ninth grade
where her teacher had students
do a graphic novel just
to see how my daughter could take
that assignment and create something
of enormous beauty and
force both intellectually
and artistically was just-- it
really just amazed all of us.
>>Andy: That's where I sort of see
all of the art of what we're trying
to do at the School of the
Future, which is to constantly stay
within the domain of the
students' authentic interest,
but to help them ramp up that
interest in those intellectual skills
so that they can achieve
more powerful things
than they would have been able to
do just left to their own devices.